[Musik]
natürlich weisen wesentlich gewollt
wirklich sonders erfolgreiches album das
aber ist ja ich finde ich muss wirklich
ohne aber nicht überstürzen könnte
vielleicht groß sie also sozialer
collien und gewinnt vor einem jahr die
castingshow the voice of switzerland und
damit einen plattenvertrag
aber was gewinnt sie tatsächlich davon
handelt dieser film
denn
[Musik]
tc wonder nennen sie ihre fans und ich
frage mich was bleibt von diesem wunder
ich begleite die 17-jährige ein knappes
jahr lang der erste morgen nach ihrem
triumph im kreise ihrer liebsten und der
schweizer presse tiziana wurde über
nacht zum star
den einstieg ins musikgeschäft muss sie
aber noch finden
sie wird ins kalte wasser geworfen
nur kann sie schwimmen erster schritt im
spital bülach ihrem arbeitsort tschüss
sagen
[Applaus]
für ein jahr unterbricht sie ihre
ausbildung zur fachfrau gesundheit einen
tag pro woche geht sie weiter zur schule
das hat sie mit ihren eltern so
ausgemacht aber zuerst will sie in der
musikwelt ihr glück versuchen
ich treffe tiziana eine woche nach ihrem
sieg wieder in ihrem neuen alltag dazu
gehört auch das beantworten der fanpost
foto nina mehr gehabt so der volkschor
ganz große axt über und dann ist es zeit
ihre liebe sozialer du kannst so gut
singen liebe grüße an ihnen gehört und
wie kaschmir negative stimmen um
negative stimme gibt es ganz viel und
ich kann es klar seitdem wird er briefe
und so aber es gibt es auf www als sie
eine tolle siegen wir zwischen
ich bin ratlos sie spezielle verstanden
sondern das gedacht beleidigungen man
eigentlich nicht es ist nett stelle so
man im ausland mit dem was in der 77 die
bonus sind und sozialer lebt jetzt nicht
mehr im casting märchen sondern in der
realität
das spürt sie auch bei ihrer single mit
ihr hat sie die castingshow gewonnen
aber in der hitparade geschafft sie ist
damit nur auf platz acht
[Musik]
die presse kennt kein pardon
das neue bio diesel sind es gar nicht
laufen ja getroffen
schon nach summen locker verkraften doch
nicht so gut oder was ist der grund
vielleicht viele fans dem pausenhof
youtube oder person gespeichert und so
katja colino macht sich keine sorgen um
ihre tochter fuso media oder das ist
wirklich sehr bodenständig und hat einen
starken charakter und ich muss keine
angst haben dass wirklich und naja sagen
wir du dich das reinigen und das
80-jährige mit allen immer gefallen und
ja
[Musik]
einen monat später in zürich tiziana tut
mit ihrem weiß coach marc sway durch die
schweiz
[Musik]
heute ist das letzte konzert der tour
sozialer gehört hier längst dazu marc
sway sagt wie tizians weiterkommen sei
nicht erfolgt das wichtigste was
gesellschaftlich so lästig sagt dass sie
immer bewusst dass an manchen und
millionären und große hitze und viele
autos wander und gas hat mahnmals dass
gar nicht alle hand wenn sie das wort
dann hat's jetzt sitzen und
musikalischer war oft bewussten wagen
anfang dame gewöhnt die erste mannschaft
konnte hofft über ganze land zieht um
[Musik]
wer schließlich und dann groß größer
das konzert beginnt im publikum
tizians eltern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tiziana hat von dieser konzert ohne viel
profitiert nach dem konzert wird max wey
von den zuschauern umschwärmt
tiziana vor allem von ihrer familie
nach diesem abend ist mir klar
ntc aner etwas gewinnt dann ist es die
chance ihre musikalische identität zu
entwickeln
juni 2014
der höhepunkt ihrer jungen karriere
dezember tritt beim elton john konzert
in st gallen auf 20.000 menschen werden
erwartet
aber ausgerechnet heute fühlt sie sich
nicht gut
ja ich bin ein haar hätte müssen
die bauchschmerzen sind noch da
aber die vorfreude ist trotzdem groß
nicht nur bei der mutter
ja ich mich dass ich trotz lädt für
diesen schon das ganze gegenteil für den
erfolg kommt zu unserem begeistern und
das ziel auf 20 verbrauchers geortet
haben
tizians grosse moment ist gaal
wie kommen sie an die mieten gefühl
wieder so merkel
[Musik]
von den erwarteten 20.000 sind erst
einige hundert an
[Musik]
o
aber diese kann sie für sich gewinnen
[Applaus]
die große masse kommt erst zum auftritt
des superstars
[Musik]
dieser tag spezieller unvergesslich
obwohl er ganz anders war als erwartet
ob sie hätten schon getroffen hat
tiziana hat es offensichtlich genossen
in den folgenden monaten hört man nichts
von tiziana ist sie auf bevor sie
richtig in war
sie hat sich zurückgezogen in diesem
zucker keller
hier entsteht ihr album nach dem single
stop wird sie von der plattenfirma noch
was neu erfunden
es geht um geld tiziana ist nur eines
von vielen projekten und das muss gewinn
abwerfen
[Musik]
also was sie hat nicole haupt politik
berührt wenn sie sind als geschenk oder
dir die die sind super wenn irgendwelche
rocksänger wenn irgendwas playback
gedruckt historische lud und so denn
strom
pedrosa und das ist sehr wenig oder
womöglich würde ich sagen in ihrem fall
also nicht jetzt irgendwie mit der band
mit noch erster linie darum zu erlösen
ich glaube es muss wirklich relativ hoch
in der immer gute guter begriff ich
verstehe was das für ihn bedeutet die
tour ist ein stil nicht die
auseinandersetzung mit der person der
künstlerin tiziana ihre wünsche haben
wenig platz
[Musik]
scott zum nach unterstelle dass ich
meine mal auf noch liegt ca
wenn sie also einfach druck ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
mit wild aber das macht schon mehr aber
es ist okay wurde war ich ganz klar was
du willst ja ja ja dachte mir ich glaub
wähle kommt einfach schwarzer kanal so
gut und so dachte ich spüre dann mann
soll sich in der kultur ihres ich nicht
so dass wir uns jetzt endlich mehr
doch ja aber auch bei der songauswahl
ist die einfluss begrenzt
ihr größter wunsch ein eigenes lied auf
dem album wird nicht erhört dabei hat
sie eigens eines mit marc sway
geschrieben
[Musik]
kharja stadt auf eigene songs setzt man
vermehrt auf hits von bekannten
künstlern
[Musik]
ein halbes jahr nach ihrem sieg
erscheint das album ein paket von der
postboten an die haustür und nicht etwa
eine plattentaufe mit party in einem
club
das sei nicht mehr üblich sagt die
plattenfirma die große tag stand das
wasser rund 50 pressetermine absolvierte
zwar insgesamt begleitet wird sie dabei
von ihrer freundin tanja und vom kamel
von der plattenfirma
sie muss wieder ins gespräch gebracht
werden
mit der neuen scheibe entschädigen muss
nicht alle anzeigen muss ich das zweite
tiziana auf promo-tour hier bei radio 24
heute ja sicher er wirkt locker aber
glaubt sie wirklich an ihren erfolg
natürlich normal aber ich erwarte ich
bin dankbar
tiziana macht was sie kann
ob das reicht
eine woche später ist klar das album
verkauft sich nicht
platz 21 in den charts melanie c core
zwischen dem sieg und dem alkohol ist
und ich dachte verlegt als sehr sehr
viel blut verloren die celtics in orken
cool und dann hat soviel um die ohren
dass nehmen obwohl die mir sehr viel für
mich aber sie haben eine mikro an
ihr vater ist überzeugt der weg hat sich
gelohnt
ohne wenn und aber sie ist ganz tolle
geschichte
meine tv musik machen damit musikszene
klingelberger es geht gar nicht um
abheben und riesenerfolg gemeine volk
das wo man sich erkannt wie monsters
basis machen aber einmal der matrix
sehen und einmal vierter und einmal neu
grund 8 gipfels sehen entspannend
tiziana macht wieder mit ihrer
ausbildung weiter der große erfolg als
musikerin blick auf den sprung vom
casting sternchen zum musikstar hat sie
nicht geschafft aber sie konnte
erfahrungen sammeln erfahrungen von
denen andere ein leben lang träumen
ihr album titel wurde zu ihrem
lebensmotto find your way findet einen
weg
ihre suche hat erst begonnen
[Musik]
mit solarzellen unauffällig ist